Musik Erstmal ist die Nackenmuskulatur. Wie muss man sich eigentlich in Stefan Titzel zwei Minuten Voraufnahme des Podcasts vorstellen? Wie gehst du an die Aufgabe ran? Ich habe mir so ein Schweissband umgemacht um mein Handgelenk und habe mir ein paar Liegestütze gemacht, um die Muskeln ein bisschen anzuspannen. Und dann habe ich ein Schlückchen getrunken. Erst mal ein Glas Honig? Nee, ein Glas Segermeister, um locker zu werden. Und ein Glas Honig auch, genau. Weil dann wird die Stimme davon gut. Ich glaube, man merkt, das ist unglaublich. Wollen wir anfangen? Ja, fangen wir an. Hallo meine Damen und Herren, herzlich willkommen zur Folge ... Ach Gott, das geht schon wieder los, die Energie ist im Keller. Herzlich willkommen zur Folge sechs des Podcast-Ufos. So, erstmal ein paar Entschuldigungen vorweg. Nee, erstmal Entschuldigung, genau, wir sind letzte Woche nicht erschienen und ich weiss nicht, woran es lag, wir haben es einfach vergessen, glaube ich. Ja, genau, und unsere Fans haben es komischerweise auch vergessen. Wie konnte das denn passieren? Es hat sich niemand beschwert. Ja, komisch. Aber das ist wirklich so typisch, das ist so unprofessionell. Ich meine, ich bin kein Profi, ich weiß nicht, wie das Podcastgeschäft funktioniert, ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich kenne auch keine Podcaster, ich finde, du machst das im Prinzip schon sehr gut. Na, aber ich bin kein Profi, aber ich glaube, dass es nicht gut ist, wenn man nicht regelmäßig erscheint. Ich habe tatsächlich heute mit unserem einzigen Fan gesprochen und die hat gleich gemeint, wann kommt die nächste Folge und ich habe gesagt, wir nehmen heute auf und dann, ach was, ihr habt noch nicht aufgenommen, so lange dauert es noch. Also da ist schon Interesse da, ich glaube, das Problem bei diesem Podcast liegt weniger im Interesse, sondern beim Angebot. Ich glaube, das Interesse ist da, darin liegt es nicht, aber das Angebot ist halt sehr schlecht. Wir haben tatsächlich, muss man auch sagen, die Themen heute sind sehr schwach. Wir haben sehr schwache Themen heute ausgesucht. Von daher, Stefan, ja, wie war die Woche? Die Woche war scheiße. Ich erlebe auch im Moment nichts. Deswegen ist es vielleicht auch gar nicht so schlecht, dass wir so lange gewartet haben. Also ich erlebe sehr wenig im Moment, weil ich bin den ganzen Tag nur immer hier zu Hause und lerne oder oder sowas. Es ist wirklich wahnsinnig langweiliges Leben im Moment. Das ist einfach so das typische Studentenleben eben nicht. Also man sitzt hier, ich habe so Cracker hier liegen den ganzen Tag und so eine Wasserflasche Wolvik. Wenn schon die Cracker das Erste sind, was du erwähnst, dann muss es wirklich im Argen liegen. Es ist wirklich langweilig hier. Das Erste, was dir einfällt, sind die Cracker. Aber kannst du nicht intellektuell, geistig damit irgendwie auseinandersetzen, irgendwie deinen Horizont erweitern, irgendwie in neue Sphären vordringen?
Nein, hier liegen Dinge, damit ich nicht aufstehen muss.
Alles liegt hier im Rad, in meinem Bewegungsradius des befahrbaren Schreibtischstuhls und ich muss mich nicht mehr aufstehen, den ganzen Tag nicht.
Und das ist halt so sehr, sehr langweilig, deswegen bin ich auch echt froh, dass du jetzt mal hier das Ding...
Sind wir eigentlich in der Krise?
Ja.
Seit Folge 1 in der Krise.
Und ich mochte ... Aber ich glaube, wir kommen raus langsam. Ja, wir kommen ... Stetig raus. Das ist so ein wahnsinniger Scheißanfang eigentlich. Nein, würde ich nicht sagen, oder? Doch. Herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zum Podcast UFO. Zu Folge sieben. Stefan Tietze ist auch da. Und Stefan Tietze, du hast ja ein kleines bisschen was vorbereitet. Und zwar aus unserer Namensgebungsphase hatten wir noch andere Ideen, wie wir unseren Podcast nennen konnten. Und ich glaube, ein Vorschlag, und der gefällt mir immer besser, war der Podcast Torpedo. Hat mir auch immer gut gefallen. Doch, glaube ich, hatten wir schon. Ich glaube, wir hatten das Podcast, den Podcast Torpedo. Das war wieder einer von deinen Ideen, die gut waren, aber die du niemals ausgesprochen hast. Das sind die meisten Ideen. Zurück zum Thema, Spaß beiseite. Wir haben heute super Themen, also entgegen deiner Ankündigung, die sind super. Wir wollen über Möbel reden, Möbel, wer kennt sie nicht, und wir wollen reden über Möglichkeiten, aber das hat keinen tieferen Sinn, sondern es fängt einfach auch mit Mö an. Wir wollten heute einfach mal die Möglichkeiten entdecken. Ja, Möbel. Möbel, Möglichkeiten mit Möbeln, was kann man mit Möbeln machen, wohin kann man sie stellen, kann man sie anders benutzen als der normale Mensch, kann man sie vielleicht mal umdrehen, Möbel, kann man sie anfassen, sollte man sie vielleicht nicht anfassen, weil sie heiß werden. Das sind so Dinge, die uns umtreiben. Ich kann ja tatsächlich mit Möbeln überhaupt gar nichts anfangen. Ich war letztens beim Friseur und habe mich da durch die ganze Frauenzeitschriften geblättert.
Und da gibt es ja ganze Sinnkosmen, die da entwickelt werden in diesen Zeitschriften, von irgendwelchen Hartholztischen und irgendwelchen Flamenco-Schemel und irgendwelche Kommoden und wirklich solche Möbel, wo man sich denkt, eigentlich braucht die kein Mensch. Irgendwie so ganz kleine Tische oder ganz grosse Stühle. Ja, das sind meistens die Möbel, wo man nicht weiss, wie sie heissen. Also wenn du in den Laden gehen würdest und nachfragen würdest, würdest du nicht, wie die heissen. Ich glaube, das ist auch eine gute Kaufempfehlung. Wenn du etwas kaufen willst, aber nicht weisst, wie es heisst, kauf es nicht. Ganz einfach. Das ist ein sehr einfacher Ratschlag. Und ich habe tatsächlich wirklich das Glück, Hobbys zu haben, die so gut wie nichts kosten. Ich bin wirklich heilfroh, dass ich mich nicht für Inneneinrichtungen interessiere, weil das ist ja schweineteuer, das Zeug. Dieser Hartholz-Super-Schemel kostet wieder 8000 Euro, weil der aus irgendeinem Superholz ist und so. Und ich bin so froh, dass ich mich hauptsächlich für Pornos und Online-Rollenspiele interessiere, weil das nichts kostet, überhaupt nichts, im Gegensatz zu 6000 Euro für ein Hartholz-Schemel. Na gut, 13 Euro im Monat für WoW und dann nicht zu vergessen, das womit du gerade aufnimmst, Mikros im Wert von einer Million Euro, würde ich sagen.
Ja gut, aber ja okay, von mir aus.
Aber es ist nichts gegen Hartholz, es ist nichts gegen so einen Hartholz-Schreibtisch aus Mahagoni, der aus dem Tropen kommt und krass gehärtet ist.
Das ist nicht so vergleichbar, das stimmt.
Aber ich glaube, also gibt es so...
Bist du ein Mensch, der Möbel denn an sich für sinnvoll erachtet in der eigenen Wohnung, zumindest im Grundbestand? Nein, aber würdest du da unterscheiden zwischen, also ich kategorisiere ja alles in Hobbys. Also das ist so meine Weltsicht, für mich ist alles ein Hobby. Ich kategorisiere immer nur in gut oder schlecht. Oder ich dachte erst, es wäre gut, weil es denke ich von allen Dingen, bis ich sie habe oder nicht mir spannend finde und dann als schlecht das ist so ein falsifikations prinzip bei mir im leben ja tatsächlich weil ich glaube ein mensch hat einfach nur ein gewisser mass an hobbys die er kapazitär unterbringen kann und es gibt natürlich hobbys die viele menschen haben wie zum beispiel körperhygiene ist ein relativ weit verbreitetes hobby da haben viele menschen spaß dran das würdest das als Hobby betrachtest... Natürlich ist es ein Hobby. Es sind halt Interessensfelder und es gibt halt einfach manche Interessensfelder, die man von der Gesellschaft denkt, man müsste sie haben, aber eigentlich überhaupt nicht hat, wie, keine Ahnung, Mode oder Innenarchitektur oder irgendwie Supersachen oder sowas, aber die man eigentlich gar nicht haben muss. Deswegen, meine Frage an dich, was ist das schlechteste Hobby, das man haben kann? Das ist wieder so eine Frage, wo man jetzt einen Mördergag raushauen könnte, wenn man gut wäre. Apropos. Keine Ahnung, also so mega abgefahrene Hobbys, weiß ich nicht. Ich finde, WoW spielen schon ein abgefahrenes Hobby. Also ich glaube, das schlechteste Hobby, das man haben kann, ist Shoppen. Also, Geldgeben an sich als Hobby zu haben, ist glaube ich so das Unvorteilhafteste, was es überhaupt gibt. Ja, das stimmt. Weil das vereinigt alle negativen Eigenschaften, die ein Hobby haben kann. Geld ausgeben. Und macht einfach das rein zum Hobby. Das ist so das Allerschlimmste. Das ist wie wenn du als Hobby zunehmen hast. Nicht Essen, sondern irgendwie zunehmen. So der Negativteil. Nur das ist dein Hobby. Shoppen, ich gebe gerne Geld aus. Aber Möbel und Inneneinrichtungen als Hobby zu haben, hat ja auch viele Vorteile. Also wenn mal Leute bei dir zu Besuch sind, dann hast du halt verdammt viele Möbel. Ja genau, dann kriegt jeder einen Schrank zu verfehlen. Genau, und jeder hat was zu tun, den ganzen Abend kann er rumspielen mit Dingen, die in der Wohnung rumstehen und die man irgendwann mal gekauft hat. Das hat schon Vorteile. Shopping hingegen hat null Vorteile. Die Frage ist, wo hört ein Möbel auf, ist meine Frage an dich. Das ist aber auch meine Frage. Ist ein Teppich zum Beispiel ein Möbel? Ja, oder ein Bild an der Wand, ist das ein Möbel? Das ist nämlich die Frage. Möbel kommt ja von mobil, Möbel sind per se mobil im Gegensatz zu Immobilien und somit ist eigentlich alles auf der Welt Möbel. Also die Welt ist ein grosses Möbel. Also ein Bett ist ja ein Möbel, aber ist auch die Matratze ein Möbel? Man kann sie auch bewegen, natürlich, dann ja. Aber es ist ja alles ein Möbel, dann ist ja auch ein Papierkorb ein Möbel. Auch Flugzeuge sind Möbel. Eigentlich sind Menschen auch nichts anderes als Möbel, als beliebte Möbel. Irgendwann hört dieses Wort auch auf, seine Bedeutung zu haben. Möbel ist ein ultrascheiss Wort. Aber wer kommt denn auf die Idee? Ich kann mir nur vorstellen, irgendwie so einen Konferenzraum, Freunde, irgendwie diese Tische, Stühle, irgendwie, wir brauchen da ein knackiges Wort und dann sagen so ein Praktikant Möbel! Und dann ist einfach Feierabend, dann war einfach Feierabend. Es hatte niemand die Gelegenheit, nicht zu widersprechen. Es fand auch niemand gut mehr, es war einfach ein wahnsinnig langer, langweiliger Tag bestimmen, wo viele dämliche Wörter wie Löffel und so festgelegt wurden, alle Mitarbeiter hatten keinen Bock mehr, und dann hat man sich gesagt, Möbel, ja komm, nehmen wir es einfach. Das war echt gut, wenn man alles Schlechte auf der Welt auf diesen einen einzigen Tag zurückführen könnte, wo die Kommission einfach keinen Bock hatte und man merkt das noch, bis in die Jahrzehnte, da wurde alles erfunden, da wurde Hitler erfunden, der Holocaust und das Wort Möbel.
Nein, das war der Tag, nachdem der Göffel erfunden wurde, wo man sich dachte, jetzt kann, es kann nichts mehr, wir können nichts mehr erfinden, was annähernd dem Göffel das Wasser reichen kann. Wir können nichts mehr erreichen. Leute, das war es mit uns und das war der Tag danach. Da hatten alle keinen Bock mehr, waren verkatert von der Party danach. Oh, jetzt ist alles runtergefallen hier. Und dann dachten sie sich, ne komm, einfach Möbel jetzt nehmen und so. Das ist auch so ein Wort, wenn man das ganz oft ausspricht, dann klingt es ganz komisch. Ja, vor allem, ich hatte letztens eine wahnsinnig intensive Diskussion im Internet. Ich bin ja jemand, der lässt sich dazu hinreisen, im Internet zu diskutieren. Und zwar ging es um die gute alte Battle zwischen etwas macht Sinn und etwas ergibt Sinn. Und irgendjemand hat es in seinem YouTube-Video gesagt, es macht Sinn. Das langweiligste Battle der Welt. Ja, natürlich. Und er hat darunter geschrieben, das heisst nicht macht Sinn, weil machen kann man nur Unsinn. Ne, ne, und es heisst eigentlich, er gibt Sinn. Und ich war früher auch mal so ein richtiges Grammatikarschloch, aber da muss ich einfach sagen, alter, scheiss doch drauf. Vor allem die Übersetzung make sense, das kann man überhaupt nicht so übersetzen, egal. Auf jeden Fall ging es dann um das Thema Wortveränderung, wie sich Worte verändern im Laufe der Zeit. Man sagt ja zum Beispiel, Shakespeare hat wahnsinnig viele Redewendungen und Worte eingeführt, die es davor nicht gab in seinen Theaterstücken, zum Beispiel to be in a pickle, also das bedeutet, in einer scheinbar ausweglosen Situation zu sein, in einer problematischen Situation sich zu befinden, I am in a pickle, aber da dachte ich mir, also pickle heisst ja Gewürzgurke,, ja. Und da dachte ich mir, wie kam das beim ersten Mal an, als dieses Stück Uraufgeführt wurde und irgendjemand eine Pistole auf jemanden richtet und er sagt, oh mein Gott, I'm in der Pickel. Und das Publikum so schweigend. Was hat er gesagt? Einer hat es gegoogelt, aber nicht gefunden. Genau. Ja, aber das ist schwierig. Also solche Worte haben ja, glaube ich, jeder von uns schon mal versucht, ein eigenes Wort zu etablieren und unterzubringen in dem normalen Sprachgebrauch und das klappt einfach nicht. War Shakespeare nicht auch der, wo man mittlerweile denkt, es waren mehrere Personen? Ja, glaube ich, kann schon sein, ja. Ich, ohne mich da auszukennen, glaube, es waren mehrere Personen, aber alleine, weil ich nicht einem so diesen ganzen Ruhm gönne. Glaubst du auch, dass du mehrere Personen bist? Nee, weil ich gönne mir ja den Ruhm. Ach so, verstehe. Also alles Gute, was ich mache, wenn ich was Schlechtes gemacht habe, wenn man eine Phase hat, wo ich alles versäbel und Wörter erfinde wie Möbel oder so, dann würde ich sagen, ja, ich bin mehrere Personen, dann kann man geteiltes Leid und so. Zum Thema Möbel habe ich genau eine Anekdote, die würde ich gerne raushauen, und zwar Du, deine Anekdoten, die du dir vorher ausdenkst, die nie so passiert sind. Mein Gott, es ist eine heitere Beobachtung. Mein Gott, wir wollen doch irgendwo ins Thema reinkommen. Und zwar hatte ich früher als Kind in meinem Kinderzimmer hatte ich einen Sitzsack. Aber eigentlich, also kein Sitzsack, es ist eine Hängematte für eine Person. Es ist eine Hängematte, die so gross ist wie eine Person. In meinem Kopf ist jetzt ein riesen 404-Error-Zeichen. Ich dachte erst, erst war ich bei Sitzsack, dann war ich bei Hängematte und da gab es für mich keine logische Verbindung. Es ist halt eine kleine Hängematte, aber es ist an einem einzigen Seil aufgehängt. Eine Hängematte hängt ja an zwei Punkten, wird es fixiert und der Sitzsack wurde nur an einem Teil. Also es ist einfach ein schwebender Sack, ein hängender Sack, ein Hängesack, in dem man sich reinlegt oder sitzt und dann sitzt man da drin. Das Problem war nur, dass dadurch, dass es nur an einem Punkt fixiert war, es sich ja nach Belieben drehen konnte, einfach. Und dann sitzt du da in diesem Ding und schaust Fernsehen und merkst einfach, wie du ganz langsam dich einfach drehst und du kannst nichts dagegen tun. Und der Film macht keinen Sinn mehr, weil man gerade einen Müll verpasst hat. Und dann guckst du erst wieder 20 Minuten die Wand an, bevor du wieder einmal komplett durchrotiert bist und dann wieder 20 Minuten lang einen Film anschauen kannst. Deswegen habe ich auch sehr schlechte Erinnerungen an die meisten Filme aus meiner Jugend und auch Videospiele haben relativ selten Sinn ergeben, weil ich einfach 20 Minuten lang in der Gegend rumgestanden bin. Also das ist nur eine Anekdote, aber irgendwann hatte ich dann auch immer einen Stock in der Hand, als ich da drin saß und habe dann wie so ein venezianischer Gondoliere durch diesen Sitzsack durch auf dem Boden so mit dem Stock geschrappt, damit ich wieder in der richtigen Sitzposition war. Also es war ein konstanter Kampf, meine Jugend war ein ewiger Kampf, aber es hat irgendwann funktioniert. Das ist das dümmste Mobiliar, was ich je mal in seinem Leben gehört habe. Das ist so dämlich. Was will man, wenn man sitzt? Was will man? Man will einfach sitzen, Punkt eins, und zwei ist, halt um irgendwo eine bestimmte, etwas auszuüben. Wenn man guckt irgendwo hin, aber man macht irgendwas, aber man will sich nicht dabei drehen. Das ist eigentlich der einzige Vorteil, den ein Stuhl hat, ist, es gibt immer eine Situation im Alltag, wo du dich nicht drehst. Das ist eigentlich das einzige, was man mal will. Man sagt, Freunde, jetzt mal eine Stunde lang einfach nicht drehen, bitte. Ist es nicht der Film Fight Club, wo die am Anfang relativ zu Beginn sagen, dass Möbel immer so ein Selbstausdruck sind, also quasi das Möbel ausdrücken, das Innerste von dir in die Wohnung quasi transformieren. Ja, es ist so ein bisschen so ein Nesting-Instinkt, man macht sich sein eigenes Nest und die Hauptfigur im Fight Club kauft sich ja auch so ganz viele Ikea-Möbel und so einen Yin-Yang-Tisch, um irgendwas auszudrücken, dass er wie im Gleichgewicht und Harmonie ist. Aber es ist auch so ein Teetisch oder so ein Kaffeetisch, auch für mich komplett überflüssig. Aber ich glaube, das geht halt einfach nicht um. Nee, aber was sagt das denn über dich aus? Was sagt denn dieses Hängeding über dich aus? Ich bin ein chilliger Typ. Du hängst im Leben, aber du findest noch keinen Halt, bis du irgendwann mal auf die Idee kommst, im Alter von zwanzig dir so einen Stock zu nehmen, der dir Halt gibt vielleicht.
Es ist ein bisschen wie Traumdeutung, es ist nicht so ganz verifizierbar.
Möbeldeutung, finde ich, ist ein schönes neues Schema der Psychoanalyse, kann man eigentlich mal sich reinsteigern. Sehr gut, Möbeldeutung.
Möbeldeutung, was hat man für Möbel?
Ich habe das nämlich immer mal erfahren, dass es Möbel Selbstausdruck sind.
Und dann ging es nämlich los, dann musste ich meine Wohnung, da bin ich da umgezogen, bin ich nach Köln gezogen und musste dann meine Wohnung einrichten. Und dann, aber dann frage ich mich auch irgendwie, ob das nicht zunichte gemacht wird, dieses Möbel ist ein Selbstausdruck, wenn man das weiss. Weil wenn man das weiss, versucht man natürlich, das zu manipulieren, damit man cooler wirkt. Ja, aber welche Möbel sind denn cool? Also ich zum Beispiel habe dann mir, daraufhin habe ich mir dann, genau, und ich habe mir ein Regal, so ein richtig, richtig altes, geiles Bücherregal geholt und das mit ganz vielen Büchern versehen. Alleine, damit ich dachte, also wenn ich mir nachher den Raum angucke und denke, das ist ja Selbstausdruck, wow, du bist ein ganz schön belesener, cooler Typ. Aber das Wissen macht das kaputt, glaube ich. Also tatsächlich würde Möbelkauf mich extrem davon abstrecken, umzuziehen. Und ich habe mal sechs Monate lang in einem Studentenwohnheim gewohnt mit eingerichteten Möbiliar. Und es war halt nicht noch, da bin ich reingekommen und es war halt klassisch, irgendwie Schrank, Waschbecken, alles da. Aber dann stand noch so ein Bonusobjekt da, und zwar ein komplett gelber Plastikwürfel, der ungefähr so eineinhalb mal eineinhalb mal einen Meter gross war, und es war wie so ein riesengrosser Legostein mit vier Rollen unten dran. Ich stell mir grad vor, wie du da reinkommst und mit allem klarkommst, aber mit diesem
Ding nicht und dann erst mal so vier Tage einfach stehen bleibst und es anguckst.
Ja genau und ich dachte mir schon, oh ich habe viel weniger Ahnung vom Studentenleben, als ich dachte, was ist das, was praktiziert man darauf, braucht man das? Hast du es untersucht und so? Also es war komplett hohl, es war wie so ein harter Luftballon, aber halt als Würfel und wirklich mit so Legostein-Noppen oben drauf. Aber nicht jetzt acht wie beim Legostein, sondern neun, es war ja quadratisch. Komplett, komplett unnutz. Also ich dachte mir, was ist das? Und ich habe so, wie es war, genommen in meinen Schrank getan, damit war der Schrank voll und habe dann einfach so gelebt und habe einfach meine Kleidung irgendwie an die Wand gehängt.
Und das war echt, wo ich auch dachte, damit verarschen die doch einfach Leute im Studentenwohnheim, oder? Also die irgendwie unsichere Leute so, ja, ich bin jetzt nach Berlin gezogen, aus meinem Elternhaus, hallo, ich lebe jetzt alleine. Und dann stellen die einfach irgendwelche random Gegenstände in den Raum. Nee, ist das ein bisschen 2001 und ist ja im Weltraum, oder? Einfach so ein Kastenobjekt, der da mitten im Raum steht und man weiß nicht genau, was man damit machen soll. Den Trösler haben wir schon auf ihren Raum gestellt, Herr Will. Okay, ja, danke, klar, alles klar. Aber ist es so, dass du dann quasi nicht gerne Dinge, also wenn du dich nicht gerne einrichtest, dann baust du ja auch generell wahrscheinlich nicht so gerne Dinge auf, oder? Weil ich hätte zum Beispiel diese so Aufbauspiele im Internet oder so einfach am PC, so halt Aufbauspiele, Strategieaufbauspiele, habe ich mal voll gerne gespielt und ich richte auch gerne Wohnungen ein oder so. Aber ich finde das einfach ganz cool, Dinge aufzubauen, bis wir halt fertig sind. Also virtuell kann ich da viel damit anfangen, aber im Real Life ist das einfach zu aufwendig. Bist du ein Minecraft-Fan? Ich überhaupt nicht. Sind Minecraft-Fans nicht supergute Inneneinrichter oder so? Wahrscheinlich. Ich glaube, wir werden eine Generation von unfassbar guten Inneneinrichtern heranzüchten. Außen-Ausseneinrichter wird nicht gut. Alles aussen, alles unfassbar hässlich. Hast du Bilder an den Wänden eigentlich? Nein, überhaupt nicht. Ich habe nur eine grosses, eine grosse Pappe. Ein grosses Poster von dir selbst. Genau, wo ich Sachen hinpinne, aber ansonsten überhaupt nicht. Ich überlege mir jetzt tatsächlich auch fürs Wohnzimmer, mir eine grosse Tafel zu kaufen, also so ein grosses Whiteboard, dass ich dann ganz gross ins Wohnzimmer hänge, wo man dann Sachen drauf schreibt. Das finde ich gut, weil ich finde es auch geil, wenn man dann mal einen Fall lösen will, weil gerade eingebrochen wurde bei einem oder so, dann kann man da mit so roten Bindfäden und Bildern den Fall lösen. Ja, absolut. Ich mag Möbel, die einem noch Möglichkeiten lassen. Ich mag Möbel mit Möglichkeiten. Das macht Sinn. Hast du das schon verstanden? Und zwar, so ein Whiteboard ist ja erstmal relativ unbefleckt, aber man kann damit viel machen. Man kann da ein Labyrinth draufmalen, ein Huhn, eine Ente, man kann alles Mögliche draufmalen, es ist wirklich kompatibel. Ich habe Bilder an den Ven, weiss ja auch nicht warum. Welche, wovon? Das würde mich jetzt schon interessieren, was hat denn Stefan Tietze für Bilder an der Venue? Tietze. Ich habe ein Poster zum Beispiel, und ich habe ein Pulp Fiction Poster. Ach Gott, steht da auch riesengroß, ich habe keine Persönlichkeit drauf auf dem Pulp Fiction Poster oder was steht da drauf? Also in erster Linie steht da Pulp Fiction drauf. Ach so, okay. Und dann sieht man, wie man am Tanzen. Ganz kurze Frage, bist du eigentlich jemand, der Grüße übermittelt? Also wenn dir jemand sagt, hey und grüß Punkt, Punkt, Punkt von mir, machst du das dann auch? Zwei Fragen. Erstens, wie bist du jetzt aufgekommen? Ich finde es ja gut, dass du was sagst, um mich auf dieser Möbeleinbahnstrasse zu manövrieren, aber es ist die Frage, was du gerade sagst.
Also tatsächlich, nee, weil ich habe mich gerade daran erinnert, dass heute zu mir jemand gesagt hat, ah ja, und grüß die Punktpunktpunkt von mir und nicht immer im Kopf sofort den Delete-Button, sofort, nee, meine ich, wäre ich nicht mehr. Da rein, da raus, nie. Einfach Aufgabe, so Inbox und sofort deleted, einfach sofort weg, werde ich einfach nicht tun. Und auch so Leute, die man einfach in einem halben Jahr erstmal wieder trifft und dann sagen, ja, grüß dich von Markus, Stefan, Steffen, Marc, Max zweimal und Ahmed und das funktioniert einfach nicht. Das stimmt, wenn man das wirklich immer machen würde, dann würde man wahnsinnig viel Zeit im Leben verschwenden einfach, weil es juckt ja auch keinen. Was ist da der eigentliche Hintergrund? Du bist ja auch nur der Überbringer, du hast ja nichts davon. Wenn sich ja jetzt jemand darüber freut, aber die Grüße, da hast du ja nichts von als Überbringer. Du bist ja nur der namenlose Mittelmann. Aber es ist ja auch ein Icebreaker, es kann ja auch ein Icebreaker sein. Also wenn man ein Gespräch anfangen möchte, dann kann man ja anfangen mit, ah ja, du übrigens, ich soll dir die und die Grüße ausrichten. Und dann kannst du ein Gespräch anfangen. Und dann geht es entweder los, dann geht es entweder richtig los oder man redet über Möbel und es passiert nichts, weil Möbel ein Scheiß Thema sind. Möbel geben genau 23 Minuten ein Gesprächsthema her und dann ist eine harte Sackgasse, aus der man nie wieder rauskommt. Ich glaube, das Problem war, dass wir an der Definition gescheitert sind, dass wir es nicht hinbekommen haben, Möbel richtig zu definieren. Dinge, die man in einer Wohnung hat, würde ich sagen. Ja, aber in einer Matratze ist doch kein Möbel. Man sagt auch nicht, es ist kein Möbel. Sondern, wie sagt man denn? Damit fängt es schon an. Wir wissen doch nicht, wie wir das Wort gebrauchen können. Wir sind auch schon mal in der grammatikalischen Sackgasse. Es ist ein Möbel. Mobiliar. Na ja, ist Mobiliar dasselbe wie Möbel? Möbel kenne ich jetzt Singular gar nicht. Überhaupt nicht vorbereitet auf das Thema, merke ich gerade. Überhaupt nicht. Lass uns zu Möglichkeiten übergehen. Möglichkeiten ist ein Thema, das ist auch sehr, das ist wiederum so weit gefasst, dass wir auch nicht genau das fassen können. Aber Möglichkeiten, soll man nicht lieber über Unmöglichkeiten sprechen, weil möglich ist ja fast alles mittlerweile. Ich finde, das schließt sich ja irgendwo mit ein. Das ist ja ein Thema. Aber ich möchte in einem ganz konkreten Rahmen über Möglichkeiten sprechen. Und zwar sind Möglichkeiten ja eigentlich etwas sehr Angenehmes, wenn man Möglichkeiten hat. Ja, so im Allgemeinen. Du redest doch über Freiheit gerade. Na ja. Und den Begriff der Freiheit. Ja, aber Freiheit ist ja die Möglichkeit, Entscheidungen zu treffen oder Dinge, sein Schicksal selbst zu ändern oder in die Hand zu nehmen. Angenommen, ein Sportler hat in einer Woche ein grosses sportliches Ereignis. Dann hat er die Möglichkeit, dieses Ereignis zu seinen Gunsten zu verändern und zu manipulieren, indem er trainiert. So, jetzt bist du kein Sportler, Stefan. Du bist kein Sportler. Ich bin das Gegenteil, Stefan. Du bist das absolute Gegenteil. Wenn du jetzt in einer Woche ein Vorstellungsgespräch bei Tele 5 hast, wie willst du dich darauf vorbereiten? Du kannst im Gegensatz zum Sportler dich nicht effektiv darauf vorbereiten. Und das ist ein Problem, du hast keine Möglichkeiten, du bist nur auf dich alleine gestellt und das ist ein Problem. Das ist auch interessant, bei Berufen zum Beispiel, gibt es viele Berufe, wo man die Möglichkeit hat, sich weiterzuentwickeln. Absolut. Und zum Beispiel, wenn man Dinge einsortiert, alphabetisch, kann man das Alphabet wahnsinnig gut lernen und dann kann man das sehr gut machen, bis man es irgendwann sehr schnell kann und irgendwann der Beste ist da drin, vielleicht. Es ist messbar, aber dann gibt es wieder um Berufe, wo man sich nicht... Bei künstlerischen Berufen ist es tatsächlich ein Problem, oder angenommen, jetzt mal weg vom Künstler, mehr hin zu dir, zu sagen, du hast in der Woche ein Forschungsgespräch bei Tele5, du stellst da ein neues Format vor, DocTV, stellst du vor und was machst du denn dann? Also willst, also, kannst du, was machst du? Fragst du aus einem konkreten Anlass eigentlich? Ich frage aus einem extrem konkreten Anlass, dass ich in einer Woche ein Vorstellungsgespräch bei Tele5 habe und DocTV pitchen möchte und dann noch nicht genau weiss, wie ich mich darauf vorbereiten soll. Ich wüsste ja auch nicht. Also ich glaube, du musst wahnsinnig selbstbewusst rüberkommen, zum einen. Kann man selbstbewusst sein lernen? Ja, nein. Damit fängt es schon an. Du kannst eigentlich, du musst rüberkommen. Du kannst ja lernen, so rüberzukommen, als wärst du wahnsinnig kreativ, wahnsinnig selbstbewusst, wahnsinnig toll, hübsch und so. Aber du bist es nicht in Wirklichkeit. Aber du kannst, glaube ich, lernen, so rüberzukommen, auch vordergründig. Ich glaube, Selbstbewusstsein liegt auch nicht nur daran, wie man sich gibt, sondern auch wie man Dinge rezipiert. Ja. Da erzähl mal mehr drüber. Das möchte ich jetzt einfach mal stehen lassen. Das habe ich nämlich heute darüber nachgedacht, dass ja Selbstbewusstsein ist, auch dass man Dinge zu seinem Wohl missversteht.
Also dass wenn jemand irgendwas sagt, was neutral ist, versteht man das Miss und so als hätte die Person etwas Gutes über einen gesagt.
Und dann wiederum, wenn man davon ausgeht, da man ja missverständlich davon ausgeht,
dass die Person einen mag, geht man auch mit dem Setting ran, ah, ich mag die Person
auch und dann mag die Person nicht tatsächlich auch, weil du wiederum mit dem Mindset rangehst, die Person mag mich, ich mag die Person und dann mögen sich alle, obwohl überhaupt eigentlich diese Sympathie nur aus dem Missverständnis einer selbstbewussten Person entstanden ist. Ja, das ist einfach, wenn man mit so einer positiven, wenn man lacht, lacht die Leute zurück, das ist das typische, das ist nicht die Erfahrung, die mache, ehrlich gesagt. Überhaupt nicht. Ich will auch gar nicht, dass Leute
mich zurück anlachen. Wenn ich lache,
ist es doch kein Freifahrschein für Leute,
mich einfach zurück anzulachen.
Ich lache auch generell nicht
gerne in der Öffentlichkeit, weil Leute zurücklachen
und bei den meisten, die das so aus ist,
hätten sie es lieber
lassen sollen einfach, weil die es wahrscheinlich seit Jahren
nicht mehr gemacht haben und es schon ein bisschen eingerostet.
Ja, Lachen ist tatsächlich ein grosses Problem, vor allem, du kennst ja bestimmt die Situation, jemand zeigt dir ein lustiges Video.
Und das ist immer schwierig.
Oder jemand erzählt einen Witz und du hast den Anfang verpasst und weißt dann nicht mehr genau. War das jetzt die Pointe?
Hast du zum Beispiel von Weiss diese Interviewrunde gesehen, wo ein Rabbi, ein Priester und ein Imam erzählen sich gegenseitig Witze. Zu diesem Charlie Hebdo-Geschichte haben die drei Priester eingeladen, die sich gegenseitig Witze erzählen sollen und so ein bisschen über Humor reden sollen. und der Imam hat als erster einen Witz erzählt und das war der schlechteste Witz der Welt.
Das war für mich der allerschlechteste Witz der Welt und die beiden anderen.
Es gibt nichts Schöneres, als dabei zuzuschauen, wie anderen Leuten Witze erzählen und die überhaupt nicht ankommen. Also es macht keinen Unterschied von der Reaktion her, ob die jetzt irgendwie ein Gemüsesuppenrezept erzählt hätten oder ein Witz. Das ist einfach überhaupt kein Unterschied. Null. Und es war einfach so unangenehm. Ich musste da schon wegschalten. Das war echt furchtbar. Apropos, ich bin ja auch ein bisschen in der Berühmtheit und ich wurde letztens wieder, nein, aber ich wurde angesprochen tatsächlich auf meine Berühmtheit hin. Es war eine sehr absurde Situation, weil es war, ich versuche das möglichst zu umschreiben, es war eine Redakteurin in einem sehr umstrittenen Medienportal. Sehr umstritten. Eine Redakteurin, da hast du Kontakt zu Kontakt zu? Also, die hat mich erkannt auf der Strasse. Es war eine Volontärin in einem sehr umstrittenen Medienportal. Und die hat mich nach... Pornhub. Nee, noch umstrittener. Und ich habe sehr viel Häme dafür geerntet, dass als sie mich nach meiner Handynummer gefragt hat, im Sinne von, hey, ja, irgendwie Kontakte knüpfen hier von wegen, du kennst ja ganz viele Medienleute, habe ich ihr eine falsche Handynummer gegeben. Und dafür habe ich viel Häme geerntet, wobei ich finde, dass es die einzige Möglichkeit ist, mit der Situation gut umzugehen. Also ich kann ihr nicht meine echte Handynummer geben, weil das so creepy ist. Was hättest du denn gemacht, wenn sie dich auf der Stelle angerufen hätte, um zu prüfen, ob es die richtige ist? Dann hätte ich gesagt, ich habe mein Handy nicht dabei. Oh, der ist natürlich ein Profi, da merkt man direkt eine Antwort auf Lager. Ja, klar, natürlich, das ist krass. Aber es ist ja auch sau unhöflich zu sagen, hey, willst du mir deine Handynummer geben, zu sagen, nein. Nein. Also das geht natürlich schon, gewisse Leute würden das wahrscheinlich auch machen. Also wenn es wirklich so umstritten ist, wenn es wirklich so umstritten ist, dieses Medienportal, dann wird die, glaube ich, die Erfahrung machen, dass die meisten in dieser Situation Nein sagen. Ja, ja, mag sein. Aber da denkt man, ich hätte es wahrscheinlich auch gemacht, den Falsche gegeben oder die Richtige und danach mein Handy weggeschmissen. Ja, oder andere Reihenfolge. Beziehungsweise ich habe immer so einen Sündenbock-Freund, dessen Handynummer ich immer in solchen Situationen rausgekommen. Und es war auch immer schon so, es war auch immer schon so der Sündenbock-Freund, immer wenn man irgendwie zum Beispiel der Klassenfahrt und irgendwie das Schullandheim und dann fahrt man zurück und ich rüttel irgendwie am Sitz des Vordermanns und dann steigen wir alle aus und dann sagt der Busfahrer, aha, hier, was hast du denn da mit dem Stuhl, äh, Sitz gemacht?
Ja, du, wenn der kaputt ist, dann musst du den ersetzen, gib mir deine Adresse. Und dann hat man traditionell die Adresse besagten Freundes gegeben.
Jeder hat so einen, oder?
Ja, natürlich.
Aber man braucht, von diesem Sündenbockfreund braucht man die Adresse und die Handynummer auswendig und Geburtsdatum. Und die Blutgruppe. Egal was passiert, alles auf ihn schieben kann. Und auch die E-Mail-Adresse und alles und wie viel Scheiße dieser Freund schon gefressen haben muss im Laufe seines Lebens, weil ständig irgendwelche Strafzettel oder Strafen oder Hassschriften oder irgendwas an ihn kommen und er von nichts eine Ahnung hat. Und dann hat sie mittlerweile den angerufen schon? Oder findest du das nicht raus, weil das ein Entfernter ist? Ach so, mit dem habe ich kaum noch Kontakt tatsächlich. Also die Frage ist auch, ob er es auf mich zurückführen würde. Ja, wahrscheinlich fragt sie, ist da Florentin Will. Ja, das stimmt.
Das stimmt.
Das Lügengebäude beginnt in sich zusammenzufallen.
Ja, okay.
Das ist natürlich auch ein unangenehmer Anruf.
Ja, pass mal auf.
Kannst du vielleicht aufhören, meine Handynummer an irgendwelche scheiß Leute rauszugeben?
Wie war es damit?
Und zwar ist es ja so, dass du letzte Woche mal angeteasterst, dass du in Tübingen warst, sein wirst für ein Interview. Das hast du angeteasst und jetzt wollen die Zuschauer, ich bin ja ein Mensch, der an unsere Zuschauer denkt, an unsere Vielzahl von Zuschauern und die sind bestimmt sehr interessiert zu wissen, was da passiert ist. Magst du da mal, sind da lustige Sachen passiert, Anekdoten, zum Thema Möbel oder Möglichkeiten? Es war ein schwarzer Tag meines Lebens. Nein, es war total toll. Das ist so eine Studentengruppe, die da irgendwie so immer mal wieder so Talkrunden zu zweit, also Moderator und einen Gast veranstaltet in irgendeiner Kultkneipe in Tübingen. Und da war ich eben auch eingeladen. Es waren sehr, sehr nette Leute, die sehr engagiert sind. An der Stelle kann ich ja mal auch eine Podcast-Empfehlung raushauen und zwar das Podcast-UFO. Das Podcast-UFO so einfach auf Facebook eingeben, ist ein sehr gutes Angebot. Das ist wirklich. Nee, tatsächlich waren sehr nette Leute, sehr engagiert, haben dann auch einen Einspieler gedreht für mich und im Vorhinein schon irgendwie wie im New Magazin so einen Einspielfilm gemacht und so, alles total aufwendig. Die Talkrunde an sich war auch cool, wir haben irgendwie, glaube ich, eine Stunde oder anderthalb Stunden irgendwie gelabert über alles Mögliche, über meinen unglaublich kometenhaften Aufstieg ins Medienbusiness und wie ich das gemacht habe und wie ich mit den ganzen Leuten umgehe, die meine Hände haben wollen. Und wie du dir das Standbein wieder kaputt machst mit dem Podcast-Ufo. Genau, ja, und er war auch auf jeden Fall tatsächlich toll, weil sowas habe ich noch nie gemacht, irgendwie vor Publikum irgendwie performt, ohne Konzept irgendwie, also so direkt, jetzt nicht irgendwie im Rahmen einer Fernsehsendung oder so, sondern einfach komplett direkt mässig und hat tatsächlich viel Spaß gemacht. Und ja, ich habe viele CDs bekommen von irgendwelchen Leuten, die Bands haben und deren Bands sich mal angeln soll. Hä, aber warum gibt man die, also wenn ich eine Band, ich habe tatsächlich eine Band, aber ich würde niemals auf die Idee kommen, dir eine CD zu geben. Ja, das Problem ist, ich habe jetzt hier sechs CDs rumliegen und ich habe kein CD-Laufwerk. Und ich überlege mir jetzt schon eine Mail zu schreiben, ja die CD an sich, sehr schön gestaltet, also wirklich die Farben, die ihr da bedruckt habt, weil die sind auch bedruckt, die sind relativ professionell gemacht und ganz toll. Inhaltlich kann ich relativ wenig dazu sagen, aber nee, war auf jeden Fall sehr toll, kann ich nur weiterempfehlen. Aber man sollte öfter mal zu solchen nach Tübingen fahren vielleicht. Ja genau, tatsächlich. Und es war so ein bisschen nicht ganz klar, wie ernst dieses ganze Interview gemeint war, also inwiefern man da Scheisse erzählen konnte. Und ich hatte so die Hoffnung, ich könnte da eine Ente platzieren in der Medienwelt. Und ich habe erzählt, dass ich in einer WG wohne mit Helmut Karasek. Und es waren tatsächlich auch Vertreter von studentischen Zeitungen da, die im Nachhinein gefragt haben, ja, können wir das drucken mit dir und Karasek? Und ich, ja, klar, klar, druck das, kein Problem. Der ist ja ganz entspannt damit. Und ich hätte es so schön gefunden, wenn eine Woche später irgendwie der Bildschlagzeile Florentin Will wohnt mit Helmut Karasek zusammen oder wahrscheinlich andersrum. Das ist dieser alte fiese Gag, Lokalzeitungen in die Scheiße zu reiten, die man Unwahrheiten verbreitet. Aber ich finde, das ist doch die einzige Daseinsberechtigung von Lokalzeitungen, dass sie die Einzigen sind, die einfach komplett unbeduchtend Scheiße erzählen dürfen, weil sie sagen, ja Kollege, man kann von niemandem erwarten, dass man der Lokalpresse wahr hat. Das haben wir auch immer gemacht. Fakten vermittelt, das funktioniert. Das haben wir auch immer gemacht. Ich habe immer in einer Band gespielt, wo auch teilweise sogar mal, das waren die Highlights der Karriere, eine Lokalzeitung darüber geschrieben hat. Und die besten Sachen waren immer, wenn man die genaht hat, indem man irgendwie Sachen erzählt hat. Und im Nachhinein haben die das dann aufgegriffen und dann haben woanders gespielt und dann haben die die Geschichten auch nochmal übernommen. Ja, genau. Und dann irgendwann sind so krasse Geschichten. Wir haben zum Beispiel, wir sind rückblickend, haben wir dann in Zeitungen gelesen, dass wir vor Bushido schon mal gespielt haben, also das Vorband von Bushido, was niemals so passiert ist, aber das haben wir auch niemals so gesagt. Der hat mir gesagt, ja, wir haben ja irgendwo gespielt, wo auch schon mal irgendwann Bushido gespielt hat, was auch schon nicht stimmte, aber halt nicht so eine krasse Lüge war.
Und dann irgendwann haben die Zeitungen angefangen, das nochmal aufzubauschen, das ist stille Post mässig. Und am Ende werden so krasse Mythen umeingestrickt, was echt geil ist. Lokalzeitungen sind gut zu nahen, aber sollte man nicht tun. Nein, absolut. Nee, es hat auch nicht so funktioniert tatsächlich, aber nee, es war ein sehr schöner Abend. Kann ich nicht anders sagen. Und ich bin hingeflogen und Fliegen ist tatsächlich echt krass. Ich bin tatsächlich erst ein mal in meinem leben geflogen fliegen ist echt immer unfassbar weil man ja wirklich einfach fliegt also es ist ja wirklich ja kein dummes gerede ist ja kein da gibt es diesen louis louis ck gag sehr zu empfehlender sind abkommunen aus den usa den kennt den auch eigentlich jedenfalls hat er gesagt dass er sich über leute aufregt die sich darüber beschweren, wenn sie mal warten müssen beim Flieger. Also wenn die zum Beispiel sagen, ja, schon vier Stunden an der Fliegerverspätung, sitzt immer noch hier in Berlin, wollt schon lange in Bangkok sein oder so. Aber wie du schon sagst, haltet eure Fresse, ihr fliegt. Ja, es ist unglaublich. Ihr fliegt durch die Luft wie ein Vogel. Das ist krass, ihr überwindet alle psychophysikalischen Dinge und ihr fliegt durch die Luft und ihr obet es da oben ins fucking Sandwich und könnt Fernsehen gucken. Und man kann halt runtergucken. Man kann runtergucken. Die beste Erfindung ist halt das Fenster, weil ansonsten kann man auch sagen, ja, sind wir jetzt wirklich geflogen oder sind wir durch irgendein Schienensystem gefahren? Nein, du kannst runtergucken und du kannst halt einfach sehen, du siehst halt Wolken von oben und du denkst dir, what, was ist denn hier los? Vor allem allein mal diese Vorstellung, dass es ja nicht überall schlechtes Wetter ist. Wenn es regnet und du fliegst einfach über die Wolken, ist da gutes Wetter, weil darüber sind ja keine anderen Wolken mehr. Es ist so, diese ganze Perspektive von uns Menschen, die wir auf dem Boden kreuchen und fleuchen, ist so ein bisschen eingezäumt. Du redest gerade wie so ein Kind davon, was aber erstaunlicherweise sich artikulieren kann, was aber gerade in die Welt entdeckt. Was die Welt entdeckt. Ja, aber es ist echt total. Es ist nur wie wenn ein Kind sich darüber wundert. Kinder denken ja, wenn man einen Ball nicht mehr, wenn sie den Ball nicht mehr sehen, weil jemand den hinter den Rücken nimmt, denken die, der existiert nicht mehr. Und wenn ein Kind sich artikulieren könnte, würde es sagen wie sowas, ja, dann stand ich da und dann war der Ball plötzlich weg, er war weg, er hat nicht erst nicht mehr, er hat aufgefordert zu existieren. So würde ein Kind reden und so redest du auch gerade über dieses Bewusstsein, was dir plötzlich aufgeht mit dem Fliegen. Ja, aber das ist halt schon krass, weil man aus einer zweidimensionalen Welt wird plötzlich eine dreidimensionale, man kann halt auch in der Höhe reisen. Und also die Leute, die es das erste Mal gemacht haben, die sich denken, hallo, was ist denn eigentlich gerade hier los? Wir fliegen, also das ist ja, der Mensch ist ja nicht dafür gedacht, zu fliegen, aber es funktioniert. Aber was ich mir auch letztens dachte, wie super krass ist es denn eigentlich, also man kennt ja als Mensch so Pubertät und so, der Körper verändert sich und es ist irgendwie unangenehm und es ist irgendwie eine scheiß Zeit. Aber stell dir mal vor, du bist eine fucking Raupe und du bist in so einem Kokon und danach kommst du raus und kannst fucking fliegen. Hallo, ich meine, wie funkt, sagte das jemand, gibt es dann irgendwie Doktor Sommer für Raub? Wie oft habe ich mich schon irgendwo eingenistet, eine Woche lang, und habe danach gedacht, boah ja geil, jetzt kannst du bestimmt fliegen oder so, und es war tote Hose. Ja, aber es hat nicht funktioniert. Nee, aber das ist wirklich sowas, aber ich glaube, also entwickeln die dann in diesem Kuckung das Bewusstsein, dass sie bald fliegen können, oder ist es auch für diesen Aufwachen, schlafen die da drin? Oder erzählen die Eltern denen das halt irgendwie, ja hier pass mal auf, irgendwann früh oder später kannst du fliegen und die freuen sich schon oder ist es einfach so ein Hallo, was ist denn hier los, irgendwie geist das denn? Das ist eigentlich auch schade, dass die so dumm sind, diese kleinen Viecher, dass man sich mit denen nicht mal unterhalten kann, sagen, wie hat man sich das vorzustellen? Das wäre das beste Interview. Das wäre das beste Interview.
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Dann kommt man plötzlich raus und kann fliegen. Wie hat sich das angefühlt? Apropos Fliegen, heute Abend rast ein Riesenmeteorit an der Erde vorbei, habe ich gelesen, bei Spiegel Online. Heute Abend fliegt ein Riesenmeteorit ande vorbei und er hätte theoretisch auswirkungen haben können auf das leben wenn er eingeschlagen wäre aber er schreibt ganz knapp an der erdoberfläche vorbei ist das spannend woher weißt du dass nicht wir am meteoriten vorbeifliegen mind blown ja in diesem sinne klassische aristotelische Frage, bewegt sich der Meteorit auf uns zu oder wie auf den Meteoriten? Ist alles an der Frage der Perspektive. Genau wie es, glaube ich, an der Frage der Perspektive ist, wenn man jetzt so ein kleines Insekt ist, ob man plötzlich anfangen kann zu fliegen, ob das jetzt so ein krasser Mindblow-Effekt ist oder ob man denkt, ja, hey, ist halt ein Ding, was gerade passiert. Ich fange an zu fliegen. Die meisten anderen Insekten, die ich kenne, fliegen auch. Ja, aber vor allem, also wir als Menschen kennen das ja nicht, dass sich der Körper so komplett wandelt. Also so von null auf hundert. Irgendwie so eine scheiss Raupe und dann plötzlich hast du Flügel. Nee, meinst du nicht? Nee, ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, Karneval zum Beispiel, da verändern sich Menschen sehr. Zum einen in dem, wie sie aussehen, zum anderen in dem, wie sie sich beim Benehmen. Aber niemand kann sich zurückverhandeln. Die Raupe kann das nicht. Nee, die Raupe will vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr fliegen, weil es jetzt so anstrengend ist, weil sie diese nervigen Flügel mit sich rumschleppen muss. Und die hat nicht mehr die Wahl, zu sagen, so, ich möchte es vielleicht eine Raupe wieder werden. Sie hat nicht mehr die Möglichkeit. Die Wahl. Möglichkeit. Die Möbel. Haben Insekten, haben Tiere Möbel eigentlich? Das ist ein typisches menschliches Ding. Ich glaube schon, ja. Ich glaube, die meisten Tiere haben Möbel, aber wir erkennen sie nicht als solche, weil wir einfach da nicht den Geschmack dafür haben. Die sind einfach zu geschmackvoll. Ja, ich weiß nicht. Also zum Beispiel Vögel haben ja ein Haus, was aber auch keine Immobilie in dem Nester. Und das sind aber keine Immobilien, weil man kann sie ja aus menschlicher Sicht bewegen. Sag mal, diesen Podcast, den du da immer hörst, worüber reden die Leute da? Ja, in der letzten Folge haben sie zum Beispiel darüber gesprochen, dass Vögel Nester haben. Ja, cool, das klingt gut. Das muss ich mir echt mal ansehen. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht mehr, was ich sagen will, das ist ein scheiß Thema. Ja, aber dann mach was draus, du kannst dir einfach nur sagen, dass Vögel Nester haben, das weiss jedes Kind, du musst das irgendwie weiterführen. Ich habe diesen spannenden Gedanken gefasst, dass es Immobilien sind aus deren Sicht, aber nicht aus unserer Sicht.
Das heißt, es ist immer eine Frage der Perspektive, es ist immer alles relativ.
So, jetzt habe ich noch einen Gedankengang zu Einstein geschlagen, habe von Meteoriten erzählt.
Was hast du getan? Du hast gesagt, dass Tübingen okay war.
Was soll man dazu auch gross sagen? Man kann nicht über Sachen reden, die man erlebt hat,
man muss über Sachen reden, die man noch erleben wird. Die man erfunden hat.
Die man erfunden hat, ja. Man kann nicht nur über Sachen reden, die man selbst erfunden hat. Das ist so. Ich habe alles, was ich mir zu Möglichkeiten aufgeschrieben habe, habe ich schon irgendwie gesagt und es war alles scheiße. Was hast du überhaupt nicht zu Möglichkeiten gesagt? Ich habe gesagt, mittlerweile ist alles möglich, auf eine Art. Auf eine langweilige Art ist mittlerweile alles möglich und damit hat sich das Thema auch für mich völlig erschöpft. Also möglich alles, das ist einfach für dich die Antwort. Möglich, Doppelpunkt, everything. Du kannst fliegen, du kannst sterben, du kannst leben. Fertig, das war's, das sind etwa die drei Dinge, die man zum Leben braucht. Du kannst, nee, das ist wirklich so, du kannst mittlerweile wirklich alles. Du kannst in die Vergangenheit reisen, halt nicht wirklich, aber du kannst über die Vergangenheit nachdenken, du kannst sehen, was du... Kein grosser Unterschied eigentlich. Du kannst vielleicht, ich habe zum Beispiel, jetzt rede ich in diesem Moment, ich kann mir das sogar noch einen Monat anhören, weil du es hochgeladen hast irgendwo. Gewisserweise eine Zeitreise, ja. Ja, das ist halt mehr Zeitreise als das, was jemals, als es die anfing, dass man Dinge aufzeichnen konnte, hat man angefangen, quasi auch in der Zeit reisen zu können. Es ist halt wahnsinnig langweilig, ein langweiliger Begriff, Erklärung von Möglichkeiten, aber es ist halt so, mittlerweile ist alles möglich. Oder sag mal was, was nicht möglich ist. Es ist nicht möglich, einen Cape in der Öffentlichkeit zu tragen. Das geht halt nicht, das kannst du halt nicht bringen.
Ich war mal bei einem internationalen Event des Tennissports, warum auch immer, und dann haben da Leute angefangen, ihre Nationalflaggen als Cape zu tragen. Sportler oder was? Nein, nein, nein, Leute, die da auf dem Gelände herumgingen. Okay.
Und dann war jemand, der hatte eine Deutschlandfahne, als Cape umgehangen und dann wurde der vom Polizisten ermahnt, er solle bitte das nicht als Cape benutzen, das wäre Verunglimpfung der Landessymbolik. Bitte was? Cape ist ja wohl das ehrenvollste Objekt, das man überhaupt aus einem Stoff machen kann. Ich bis dato auch. Also das ist ja ohne Brechheit. Was ist denn da los? Es würde den Körper vom Regenschützen, vor Unwetter schützen und das wäre Verunglipfung der Landessymbole tatsächlich. Ja, das ist das, was ich dazu zu erzählen habe. Das ist meine Cape Story. Es gab jetzt die Diskussion, ob man Geld zerstören darf. Ja, und zwar gab es die wo, die habe ich nämlich auch geführt. Ja, warst du da dabei? Haben wir die geführt? Ich habe die sehr offensiv geführt. Ja, und du hast nämlich überhaupt, man könnte es nicht zerstören. Und ich habe gesagt, man kann es zerstören. Und du hattest recht, du hattest tatsächlich recht. Ja, man darf Geld zerstören. In England darf man es nicht, weil dort auf dem Geldschein ein Bildnis der Queen ist und man darf keine Bildnisse der Queen zerstören. Das ist verboten.
Das heißt, man darf auch keine Briefmarken zerstören.
Ich versuche in diesem Moment ein Ein-Zenn-Stück anzuzünden. Man darf keine fünf-Euro-Scheine, zum Beispiel, oder auch keine zehn-Euro-Scheine anzünden, dachte ich, weil es ein Mittel ist, ein öffentliches Mittel, um Wert auszudrücken. Und wenn man das zerstört, dann ändert sich ja der Wert aller anderen Dinge. Das war meine Aussage, aber das ist ja egal. Nein, das stimmt nicht. Das habe ich gesagt, das habe ich tatsächlich auch gesagt, weil es ist ja so, Inflation und so, also wenn du Geld anzündest, dann ist es weg, dann ist alles andere mehr wert. Ja, ich weiß, das war ja meine Idee, dass man Geld anzündet, damit man allen anderen Menschen dadurch hilft. Genau, du wolltest Leuten helfen, genau. Deflation, ja, natürlich. Und alle würden, das ist eine scheisse Idee, was ist das für eine dumme Idee? Aber das ist ja, das ist wirklich interessant und man darf es zerstören, wenn es im eigenen Eigentum ist, was Geld ja meistens ist, wenn man es in der Hand hat. Das stimmt, ja. Also wie viel Geld würdest du sagen, hattest du insgesamt schon in deiner Hand, das nicht dir gehört, wenn du mal alles zusammenrechnest? Als Kind wahnsinnig viel. Ja, wirklich? Klar. Aber jetzt schätze mal eine Zahl. Wenn du alles Geld, was du jemals in der Hand hattest, das nicht dir gehört, addierst, kommt genau Pi raus. Stimmt, es ist tatsächlich richtig, es ist genau Pi. Dafür steht auch, glaube ich, die Euler'sche Zahl oder so, E. Stimmt, ich glaube, da gibt es so eine Konstante, ja, die man verwendet in der Physik. Das ist die Konstante, zumindest genau, in der Zahl sind alle Zahlen drin, die du jemals in der Hand hattest. Haben wir eigentlich schon genug Konstanten, ist meine Frage. Konstanten sind eine eigene Sendung wert. Ohne Scheiß, wenn Möbel fast eine Viertelstunde füllen, dann schaffen doch Konstanten bestimmt drei Zehn Minuten alleine. Oder eine ganze Sendung? Es gibt die eulische Zahl, es gibt Pi, es gibt … Ich weiss nicht, ob wir unsere Sendung so um Themen aufbauen sollten. Ich weiss nicht, ob das eine gute Idee ist. Wollen wir vielleicht ganz kurz einen Cut machen und über das Konzept der Sendung nochmal von vornherein diskutieren? Also ich würde sagen, wir sind ja aufgebrochen eigentlich als Flaggschiff der Podcast-Unterhaltung. Das hat aber, haben wir gemerkt, das hat schon vor der ersten Sendung nicht funktioniert. Bevor wir die erste Aufnahme überhaupt gestartet haben, haben wir schon gemerkt, das mit nichts. Das ist überhaupt gar nichts. Da sind wir realistisch, ein Stück weit. Wir können ja heute noch mal so ein bisschen Revue passieren lassen. Best of und einfach noch mal sagen, wo lief es falsch, was ist falsch passiert? Wir sind irgendwann abgebogen in so eine Richtung, wo wir angefangen haben, uns Anekdoten zu erzählen. Nein, falsch, Wo du angefangen hast, Anekdoten zu erzählen. Weil du achtmal drauf geteasert hast, die Joyce-Anekdote zu erzählen. Und dann habe ich sie irgendwann erzählt. Nein, das war lame. Genau, das war scheiße, weil das ist genauso wie, ja, du hast doch diese wahnsinnig geile Geschichte erlebt. Erzähl die doch mal. Ja, das geht halt dann nicht, weil die halt zu krass angeteasert ist. Nein, aber es war so, dass du immer dir Sachen ausgedacht hast, die du nie so erlebt hast, aber die du gerne, du wolltest einfach gerne Anekdoten erzählen. Da ist jetzt viel Hass drin, da ist jetzt viel Hass dabei, gerade weil wir hassen uns ja auch gegenseitig. Aber das ist doch, die eben vielleicht auch immer das als Basis nutzen, man sollte sich mal fertig machen vielleicht. Konfliktpotenzial ist auch immer Humorpotenzial. Ja, ich habe ja heute tatsächlich dein Interview gehört, das du gegeben hast. Nein, ey, diese Schweine haben die jetzt auch geschickt. Kölner Campus Radio und das war sehr unterhaltsam. Also das hat mir wirklich sehr gut gefallen. Also nochmal für alle, die noch dran sind. Und zwar wurde Stefan eingeladen, für das Kölner Campus Radioio, einer Uni, interviewt zu werden als Autor für das Neo Magazin. Und da wollte ich eigentlich auch mitkommen ursprünglich, konnte aber nicht, hatte dann Dreh und dann ist ein anderer Autorenkollege mitgekommen. Dann wurden die beiden interviewt und es war sehr, sehr toll. Und ich glaube, also an allen von dieser Sendung, glaube ich, können wir uns so viel abschneiden, da können wir noch die nächsten 30 Folgen von zehren. Allein da waren lustige Spiele dabei, da war Musik dabei, ihr konntet euch Musik wünschen. Das war ein Highlight. Es wurde auch Musik gespielt, während ihr geredet habt, was ich ganz schön fand, weil als ihr reinkommen seid, habt ihr noch geredet, ohne dass Musik läuft, aber ab dem zweiten Segment lief auch konstant Musik, während ihr läuft. Also was ich mir dachte, dass in der Redaktion passiert so, fuck, das wird überhaupt gar nichts mehr, übertönt die einfach komplett mit Musik. Man hat euch überhaupt nicht verstanden, man hat Mark überhaupt nicht verstanden. Es war komplette Anarchie irgendwann. Irgendwann haben wir angefangen, die Sendung an uns zu reißen, schlecht an uns zu reißen. Dann haben wir gemerkt, dann habe ich angefangen, an dem Mischpult rumzuspielen, weil es war für mich so ein riesen krasses Ding. Wir nehmen hier halt auch mit einem Mikrofon, wie gerade in diesem Moment, mit einem Mikrofon, sonst nichts und da war halt ein riesen Mischpult plötzlich. Das war genau wie dieser Legostein, dieser Gelbe, der in dem Zimmer war. Ich stand erstmal eine Stunde da und habe mir das angeguckt und habe das fast geil. Und dann irgendwann in Stunde eins oder so habe ich angefangen, nach Aufnahme, habe ich dann mich getraut, daran rumzuspielen. Während der Sendung habe ich angefangen, halt willkürlich random irgendwelche Zähler drum zu drehen und irgendwelche Regler hochzuziehen und wieder runterzuziehen. Und auf einmal war bei einem im Hintergrund der Deutschlandfunk oder so. Aber auch nicht der Haupt-Deutschlandfunk, sondern irgendwie so Klassik oder so. Aber auch On Air hat man das auch gehört? On Air oder hat das nur der Moderator gehört? Ja, es war in deinem Mitschnitt nicht drin, weil es schon nach 22 Uhr war, wo die Sendung eigentlich schon lange vorbei hätte sein sollen. Und da haben wir angefangen halt, da wurde es auch irgendwie auf eine Art lustig. Und dann habe ich da angefangen, irgendwelche Regler hochzuziehen. Und dann kam wirklich der Deutschlandfunk Klassik und dann haben wir noch für eine Viertelstunde oder so so einen Klassik-Track angefangen, online und eher zu kommentieren. Das heisst, du brauchst ein Mischpult.. Das heißt, du brauchst einen Mischpult, um richtig gut zu sein. Du musst deinen Gefühl in freien Lauf lassen können, du musst ein bisschen... Ich brauche zumindest etwas, was nicht von dieser Welt ist, wo ich denke, es ist nicht von dieser Welt, was ich hier habe, um es anfassen zu können. Die Cracker können diesen Job nicht erfüllen. Etwas, das hauptsächlich existiert. Genau. Ja, lass nächste Woche mal wieder eine gute Folge machen. Lass nächste Woche überhaupt mal eine Folge machen,
weil es war ja diese letzte Woche auch nicht der Fall. Wir wollten uns auch mal zurückbesinnen auf unseren Soundeffekt-Hintergrund. Weisst du was, wo ich gerade so mit meinen toten Augen in Richtung Pulp-Fiction-Poster stiele, fällt mir ein, Telta, kennst du diese Szene, wo die in einem Restaurant sitzen und dann sagt sie ihm, dass man weiss, dass man wirklich mit einem Menschen eine besondere Beziehung eingegangen ist, wenn man sich anschweigen kann?
Ja.
Vielleicht sollten wir das, ist vielleicht nicht so gut.
Das ist vielleicht nicht so gut.
Ja.
Wollen wir nächste Folge mal eine Stunde lang probieren, wie gut wir uns eigentlich verstehen?
Ja, können wir gerne machen. Also wir stellen unsere Beziehung auf die Probe, finde ich gut. Indem man sich anschweigt einfach. Ja, oder gegenseitig. Und auch die Beziehung zu unseren Hörern. Wenn das nämlich die beliebteste Folge wird bei iTunes zum Beispiel, die Folge, in der wir uns eine Stunde lang angeschwiegen haben, dann sollte man sich vielleicht Gedanken machen, vielleicht aber auch ist es ein positives Zeichen, weil sich anschweigen können ist ja anscheinend ein gutes, positives Zeichen. Nur gut. Man muss in diesen hektischen Zeiten, wo ich gerade von Klausur zu Klausur hetze, wo du von Interview zu weiss nicht was zu Burger King hetzt, in diesen hektischen Zeiten muss man auch mal schweigen können und auch mal so eine ruhige Folge haben können, finde ich. Ja, stimmt, absolut. Und naja, in gewisser Weise sind wir ja wie so ein richtig schöner Sessel. Man setzt sich rein, man kriegt Unterstützung, aber nicht zu viel, man kann sich selbst noch entfalten. Möbel bieten einem Möglichkeiten, aber auch nicht so viele Möglichkeiten, dass man droht, den Überblick zu verlieren.
Vielen Dank für dieses Schlusswort, Stefan Tietze.
Ich bedanke mich für diese Folge und ich warne noch mal nicht zu weit rausfliegen heute,
Florentin, unser Podcast-Ufo, denn ein Meteorit rast knapp an der Erde vorbei.
Bis bald!